clasifica los dibujos de acuerdo a la
ecuación que describa de manera correcta
la relación entre los vectores dibujados
una ecuación puede tener cualquier
número de tarjetas y las tarjetas que no
correspondan a ninguna ecuación se deben
dejar sin clasificar ok vamos a ver a
qué se refiere todo esto nosotros
tenemos aquí a cada uno de los diagramas
el diagrama a b c y d y aquí tenemos
algunas representaciones que nos
muestran justo aquí en cada uno de los
diagramas por ejemplo aquí tengo o más b
igual a w y vamos a ver qué me dice el
primer diagrama si yo me tomo a un ok si
yo me tomo a w y le sumó un ok entonces
fíjate que estamos juntando cola con
cabeza y entonces fíjate que mi
resultado es este vector de aquí es
decir w
me da b eso es lo que me está diciendo
el diagrama esto con estos tres vectores
entonces no sería esta primera opción
pero
w ok creo que esta opción será la
correcta así que voy a jalar este
recuadro justo por acá y ya con esto
tengo representado el primer diagrama el
primer diagrama me dice que w más o me
da el vector b
vamos a ver qué me dice el segundo
diagrama el diagrama b lo que me dice es
que si me tomo w y después le sumó menos
o menos y esto me da de es decir w menos
como vectores me debe de dar el texto
europeo bueno también lo podemos
representar de esta primera manera si te
das cuenta uno más ve si yo me tomo al
vector b y éste este de aquí lo volteó
ok me da el vector y entonces entonces
ve más y me daría el vector w pues más
de aquí mismo podremos despejar y
entonces el diagrama b es lo mismo que
la primera opción ok vamos a ver qué me
dice el diagrama 0
el diagrama se empieza con este vector y
juntamos cabeza con cola y después
tengo el vector menos w y eso me debería
de dar el vector b
ok uy - w es sometida a quedar el vector
b y bueno es lo mismo que aquí si al
vector b le sumó el contrario a éste es
decir voy a cambiar la cabeza por la
cola entonces me daría mi vector y por
lo tanto ésta va justo aquí y vamos a
ver qué me dice el último hacia este
vector y yo le sumo w entonces llegamos
al vector b hubo más w es igual a b es
justo esto que tengo aquí entonces la
voy a poner aquí y ya está
tengo clasificado cada uno de estos
diagramas en estas tres opciones que
tengo aquí así que es hora de comprobar
respuesta vamos a ver si estamos bien y
de lujo llegamos a la respuesta correcta